من جديد محمد العمده محمد يسعد صباحك اهلا
بك شكرا على تواجدك معانا انت والعود صباح
العربيه
اله العود تحديدا في الموسيقى
[موسيقى]
التراث العالمي غير المادي شو خصوصيه هذه
الاله الوتريه اذا ما قررناها مع الالات
الموسيقيه الاخرى
العود مجرد انك تحضنه
فيعطيك شعور جميل ودافع
ويعطيك ايضا مدى للتلحين ومدال
[موسيقى]
الطرب وقريب يعني قريب للقلب طيب محمد
العود موجود تقريبا في جميع العربيه
هي في ال في المقامات في مقامات
سعوديه في مقامات مصريه يعني كل كل بلد له
نمط في العزف يعني
محمد كيف بعرف انه هذا العود افضل من غيره
يعني ما هي مواصفات العود الجيد
والله شوفي انا انا ما بيفرق معايا صانع
او بيفرق معي نوعيه الخشب او بيفرق معي اي
شيء انا يفرق معي صوت
مجرد اسمع صوت العود يعني حتى حتى الاسعار
ما بتفرق معي في اعواد بيجيبوا لها
اسعارها غاليه جدا ما بتعجبني
وفي اعواد بتكون رخيصه ولكن اصواتها
بتناسبني ممسكها بيناسبني
على طول
حاضر
[موسيقى]
نسم علينا
الهوى من مفرق الوادي يا هوا دخل الهوا
خذني على
الالمان يا هوا
ياللي طاير في الهوى
كنتوا كنا نضل
[موسيقى]
يا قلبي
اكبر بيها الغربي
ما بتعرفني بلادي خذ
[موسيقى]
ني
خذني
خذني على بلا
[موسيقى]
ش طيب محمد العود يكون نفسه ويكون
المقامات نفسها شو بيخلي
الايقاع يختلف منهم من المطرب الثاني
الايقاعات تختلف يعني مثلا ااا في مصر
عندهم الايقاعات المصريه في عندنا ايقاعات
مختلفه اللي هي
ا الخليجيه العدنيه في سوريا عندهم
ايقاعات مختلفه يعني
يبغى لها حلقه كامله هذه موضوع الايقاعات
طب محمد كيف يوصنا في العازف لانه محترف
يعني فليسم كل من ضرب بريشه العود وقرار
الجواب صار محترفه
هذه الاذن السماعيه تفرق فيها كل انسان
عنده اذن سماعيه وكل انسان بيحب عازف معين
يعني بتفرق من من اذن لاخرى
حبه تسمع كمان معزوفه منك يا محمد
[موسيقى]
لو يوم احد في وحدته اكلها داعي عليك ثم
التفت وشفت ما حولك احد هذا انا من كثر ما
فكرت فيك لا تلوم
والكل منا في بلد يكفي
ايييه الى هنا وما اقدر
اوله عليك اكثر
هيله هنا ومقدر